just a crazy obsession with being right
as if the world was black and white we
live in a gray world and everyone is and
not everyone but just I'm shocked by how
many people want to fight to well I was
right I'm right this is right that's not
right and it's just destroying so many
people's happiness the reality is is
once you understand there is no right in
the scheme of things of course I get it
you can leave a comment down be like
this I get it but so many things in our
life in our world are complex and
nuanced and dramatically closer to gray
than this clear black and white there's
so many people that are incredibly
emotionally rigid and are obsessed with
the need for it to be black and white or
for them to be right take a deep breath
like a
start your journey of falling in love
with gray you'll be happier and the
people around you will be too